obama as individual protests they are
not large but in key states across the
country there are street corners that
look like this
both sides believe democracy is under
attack
this is the side entrance to
pennsylvania's convention center
mr biden and mr trump know their route
to the white house passes through it
inside they continue to count the votes
through the morning
across the state mr trump's lead has
been narrowing as the tally comes in
at one stage a media tour of the count
itself was offered by officials
just come with me and we'll get started
so we've got to cancel it
ongoing litigation why
because i've just been instructed but
after a phone call it was cancelled with
no explanation
back outside mr trump's 2016 campaign
manager turned up
with florida's former attorney general a
trump loyalist
and a court order give us details of
what you were alleging this is an
order from a judge that allows us access
to this building so our people can
monitor what's taking place
we thank you guys for the opportunity to
be here and you're going in now we're
going in right now that's what the judge
says we can do we're going to follow the
law we're going to go and make sure that
democracy doesn't die in darkness that's
what we're going to do
okay so you don't know there's been any
fraud you just want to
find out why what are we trying to hide
well yesterday you said fraud had taken
place let's go see
and with that he disappeared
the gatherings on both sides grew a
little separated by a police line
observers from the department of justice
are in there no you want to have a
democrat
and a republican to look at the vote and
decide
if they're valid i think they should
count every vote
that is legal let's make it fair and
square
i absolutely think that mr bottom will
prevail
in this city inside the count was paused
briefly to make space for mr trump's
monitors
in compliance with the order but it
wasn't enough for the president's team
they will not give us access and the
sheriff has decided not to come down
here to enforce that court order
the sheriff of your county will knock
him down and enforce
a court order what is going on in this
city
on the other side of the country in las
vegas nevada the president's men had a
witness
who they asked to detail alleged fraud
there
i went to vote and was told i already
voted i pursued the matter
and in years past i always voted in
person this time they mailed out the
ballot
and somebody took my ballot just like
pennsylvania nevada is tight
and it is disputed what a spectacle this
is then of american
democracy today made for tv appearances
by lawyers and two such opposing visions
and judgments of what's true and what's
not
the revolution will not be televised
behind the competing protests
all the unfinished counts continue they
will conclude
soon but it won't end there mark stone
sky news in pennsylvania